-...tonight is the Academy
Award-winning filmmaker
of documentaries like
"Roger & Me,"
"Bowling for Columbine,"
and "Fahrenheit 9/11."
His podcast,
"Rumble with Michael Moore,"
is available wherever
you get your podcasts.
Please welcome back to the sho
Michael Moore.
Michael, how are you?
-Great, Seth.
Thanks for having me on.
-I feel as though our
appearances together
on this show have been cloaked
in sort of an oppressive
pessimism.
Are you feeling a little bit
more optimistic
based on where we're at
as a nation today?
-Yes. And what are we going to
talk about now?
[ Laughter ]
-You know, that keeps
coming up on this show.
-No, there's a lot to talk
about, obviously.
What you just covered,
what's happening in Michigan
what happened
a couple nights ago
with the board of canvassers
all of this.
You know, we've had these
crazy Republicans in Michiga
long before Trump.
So this isn't -- it isn't that
they joined Trump's party.
Trump joined their party.
Remember, it was the Republica
governor of Michigan
that took the people of Flin
off the clean water
from Lake Huron and made the
drink from the Flint River
and poisoned the entire town
So that's the Republicans,
that's the way
they've always been in Michigan,
and this is no different,
this crazy thing that happened
there where they were
going to try to deny the peopl
of Detroit the right
to have their vote counted
-We've obviously talked
about Joe Biden
and the fact
that you liked him.
You met him at a DNC.
What was your first interactio
with him like?
-Yeah, I met him at
the Democratic Convention
in Boston in 2004, and I was
in the presidential box,
which is not
where I'm usually found.
But President Jimmy Carter had
invited me to sit with him
at the convention.
And of course this drove
Fox News
and the right wing crazy.
But in one of those --
you know where they have
those luxury boxes
at the basketball
or the football game
or whatever,
I didn't realize this
but you actually --
there's a whole area behin
the box
that's full of catered food.
So naturally I left my sea
and went back
to get something to eat,
and in through the door
comes Joe Biden.
I'd never met him before.
He sees me and he just goes,
like, "Holy --"
[ Laughter ]
Expletive.
And he comes at me,
he's all smiles
and he's shakin' my --
grabbin' my hand.
"Oh, God, I've always
wanted to meet you.
And it --
Wow, mother [bleep],
this is something. Wow!"
And he's just dropping F-bombs
And I'm like, "Whoa."
And then we start talking,
he wants to talk about
my dad working in the factor
and my mom was a clerk
and this and that.
And, you know, I knew
he always said
he was from the working class,
but I never saw it
because he always had thos
nicely tailored suits,
perfect teeth.
And within ten or 15 minutes
I realized,
"Wow, he is one of us.
He did come from
where I came from."
There's no cameras around,
it not a show or anything.
He's just being himself.
And I think what Bernie
had said about him,
that he was a good
and decent person.
And I guess in those minutes
there with him, you know,
I don't know, 15 minutes -
Can you make up your mind
about somebody in 15 minutes
I guess I decided that
he was that person.
And I have felt through
the campaign,
even though
I was helping Bernie,
I think that I felt that
if he became president,
we were going to
have a chance.
And even though maybe
our politics
didn't line up entirely,
we were going to have
a better chance getting
our thing through.
Like -- like --
-There's really a lot
of parallels with what
you're saying
to what Bernie has said
about Joe over the years,
which is one, he always make
clear we're different
on a lot of things
politically.
Two, though, he always
makes clear that
he really likes Joe Biden.
And he thinks that he can get on
the phone with him if need be.
Obviously one of the thing
progressives are up against no
is the fact that
the president-elect
is a bit more moderate.
Are you -- how do you feel lik
progressives have to try
to influence policy
moving forward?
-We may have to make sure
our voices are heard,
and we have to be heard
right now
while he's picking the cabinet
while they're deciding policy.
This is a very critical phase.
And so -- but I believe that
Joe Biden will listen.
We may not always get our way,
we may not get him
to agree with us on everything
but I think that it's
kind of like if he says
he's against Medicare for All.
But if --
when we get the Senate,
and if we pass
a Medicare for All bill
and it goes to his desk,
he's not going to veto it.
He's not going to say,
"No, I'm -- what, what?
Everybody gets health care
No way!"
He's not going to do that.
If he's for $12 an hour
minimum wage
and the bill says $15
because we --
the progressive part of this
which is really
the majority because
the majority of Americans
want a $15 an hour
minimum wage.
They want women paid
the same as men.
They believe that
climate change is real.
This is a progressive country.
I've said this many times.
And if the progressive
legislation comes on his desk,
I got to believe
he's going to sign this.
He's not going to -- he no
going to send it back.
We have a better chance
with him.
Obviously better than if Trump
had won another term.
And I'm actually --
I'm surprised, frankly.
I have to say, I don't kno
how you feel about this.
If COVID hadn't come along
would --
would Trump have won?
Would he have got
that second term?
Because here's the thing.
I've wondered about this
for months.
You know, an authoritarian
totalitarian leader
would relish to have the
opportunity to tell the people
"You will wear a mask,
you will stay indoors."
You know, that's what an
authoritarian wants to do.
They want to give orders,
and also wants to be seen
as the hero.
Take the reins of this virus
kill the virus, succeed.
Not Trump.
No, the opposite.
He doesn't do anything.
He just ignores it
or tries to pretend
it will go away by Easter.
And now we have
a quarter million dead.
Seth, a quarter million dead
is the same exact number
of people as if --
if you wake up tomorrow mornin
and you look at your phone
and it says, "Breaking news,
Richmond, Virginia,
has been annihilated.
Everyone is dead."
That would be such --
what would that do
to our collective heads?
And yet here we are tonigh
at a quarter million dead.
And we're not acting like
Richmond, Virginia,
has just been annihilated.
We're not acting like
there are now --
there's now a 9/11 every two -
every two or three days now.
We're -- I don't know
what it is,
but we need Biden and his team
to take these reins,
to get this country --
as Fauci said this week,
we need a national mandate
of how to deal with this virus
not a state by state by state.
-I want to get back,
talk about that.
We'll be right back with mor
from Michael Moore.